African swine fever is an infectious and
deadly animal disease affecting domestic
pigs and wild boar at global level
although not affected humans play a
crucial role in the spread of the virus
being in contact with affected animals
or infected clothes and vehicles can
transmit it to other areas the disease
is mainly transmitted by a direct animal
contact or dissemination of contaminated
pork the disease is not transmittable to
people the EU has been promoting many
initiatives to prevent the further
spread of ASF also at international
level the EU assists Member States in
guaranteeing that only safe unaffected
pork and pigs are treated affected
regions are being monitored and managed
to prevent further spread of the disease
in order to eradicate it
EU veterinary emergency team missions on
the ground support competent veterinary
authorities to prevent control and
eradicate ASF the EU gives priority to a
science-based approach since no vaccine
currently exists the EU is investing in
the development of a candidate vaccine
control measures are also being
developed based on a scientific input
from EPSA an effective surveillance
system has been in place for many years
in all EU Member States EU funds are
allocated and integrated in support
measures for farmers and for in you
trade this coordinated approach is
paying off as the EU was able to limit
and slow down the disease's progress and
even eradicated it in certain areas find
out more about the EU strategic approach
to African swine fever at the following
link
you